Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Tjöl mit ö. Deutschland erlaubt sich die Frechheit und scheidet aus bei einer Europameisterschaft gegen Frankreich im Halbfinale. Wo gibt es denn sowas? Ich spreche drüber mit Klaas Reese von Collinas Erben. Klaas, ich grüße dich.
Wie sagt man so schön?
Ohje, da sind wir ja schon mal beim ersten Ding. Du hast sicher den Tweet des isländischen Fußballverbandes gesehen. Ja, habe ich. Ich zitiere ihn mal aus dem Kopf. Jesus Christ, you beat us and now you steal our way to celebrate. In Richtung Frankreich. Hashtag embarrassing. Singgemäß. Ging mir tatsächlich auch durch den Kopf, wobei man, der um der Wahrheit die Ehre zugereichend sagen muss, ich weiß nicht, ob das tatsächlich jetzt etwas traditionell isländisches ist. Man hat es halt bei anderen Nationen auch schon gesehen. Ich glaube sogar, dass die Ungarn das auch schon mal gemacht haben bei diesem Turnier. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem schon irgendwie komisch, wenn du mit dem Signature Celebration Move desjenigen, den du im Viertelfinale ausgeschaltet hast, das Halbfinale feierst. Und sie haben das ja vor dem Viertelfinale auch schon gemacht im Stadion.
Ja, wenn ich das richtig gehört habe, dann wurde halt im Stadion ja auch animiert dazu. Also vor Spielbeginn hat da irgendein Animateur am Mikro dann das komplette Publikum dazu aufgerufen, das zu machen. War wohl auch ganz eindrucksvoll, klingt ja ganz gut, aber so ein bisschen komisch ist es halt. Aber ich finde auch den Tweet von den Isländern komisch.
Echt?
Das ist alles komisch. Ja, ich meine, kann man sich auch verkneifen, oder?
Ach, ich finde ehrlich gesagt, es passt zum Gesamtbild, das die Isländer abgegeben haben. Frech, dem brauchst du nicht doof kommen. Und halt so ein bisschen, ja, die spielen auch ihre Underdog-Rolle. Also so, wie du beim Poker ja auch den Smallstack spielst. Und du machst das Island auch, also, weiß nicht, aber klar kann man so sehen. Insgesamt finde ich es einigermaßen anstrengend jetzt inzwischen, wie das tatsächlich jetzt auf allen Fan-Mine gemacht wird. Und ja gut, wobei andererseits, warum findet man das anstrengend eigentlich? Warum kann ich das nicht auch einfach? Es ist ja ein schöner Jubel. Vielleicht ist das auch wieder so ein sophisticated Ding, was halt so Leute wie wir haben, die sich so viel mit Fußball beschäftigen. Und dann guckt man vielleicht auch aus so einer leicht arroganten Haltung auf so Fan-Mein-Publikum runter.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch so ein bisschen, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass halt auf diesen Tribünen, vor allen Dingen bei Länderspielen, halt wenig Kreatives zu sehen ist. Da ist mal was Kreatives da und dann ist das wie bei so einem richtig guten Song, der viel zu oft im Radio läuft, wenn man dann schon nicht mehr hört.
Stimmt, das beschreibt das ganz gut.
Ganz schneller Abnutzungseffekt und großer Hype.
Und dann kommen Coverversionen und man denkt sich, ja das macht, der Ursprungssong ist zwar toll, aber die Coverversion brauche ich jetzt echt nicht. Also ich brauche wirklich keinen Hu mit Yogi auf der Berliner Fan-Meile. Das stimmt, das trifft vielleicht ganz gut. Und andererseits ist das aber tatsächlich ja eigentlich auch der normale Gang der Dinge. Also nenne mir den kreativen Fangesang, der nicht adaptiert wurde. Das gehört irgendwie auch zu diesem ganzen Komplex dazu.
Genau und durch die Europameisterschaft ist das natürlich noch viel schneller. Und ich glaube, das macht es ein bisschen anstrengend. Dass man halt dieses Hu auf allen Ebenen, auf allen, bei allen Medien hat man es tausendmal gesehen. Und dann ist halt der Abnutzungseffekt dann da. Und man ist irgendwie ein bisschen genervt, dass das dann halt von so Animateuren dann auch noch so befeuert wird.
Ja, das geht natürlich auch wirklich nicht. Okay, ich sehe, wir sind schon ein paar Minuten in der Folge drin und haben noch nicht über das Spiel geredet. Tatsächlich ist es so, ich möchte es nicht mit dir nochmal im taktischen Detail durchgehen, denn das habe ich schon gestern Nacht gemacht in der Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz. Es soll immer noch... Ja, irgendwann macht man sowas ins Rollen und dann hat man das Gefühl, jetzt muss ich das ja nach jedem Länderspiel nachts machen. Und dann macht man das halt auch. Ich bin mir selbst gegenüber da immer sehr diszipliniert. Ja, also es gibt eine Schlusskonferenz nur dazu mit den Gästen Jürgen Kalver und David von 390, einem sehr guten anderen Podcast, den ich euch hiermit auch ans Herz legen möchte. Könnt ihr hören. Ich würde mit dir, Klaas, aber gerne über einen anderen Aspekt reden, der dann schon auch mit vielen taktischen Dingen und so weiter zu tun hat. Ich bin einigermaßen irritiert darüber, wie schnell heutzutage verlangt wird, so ein Spiel einzuordnen und vor allem mit welcher Werf dann Thesen vertreten werden, so als gäbe es nur ein richtig und ein falsch. Also jetzt, das war jetzt quasi die abstrakte Beschreibung eines konkreten Phänomens. Schon ab der 70. Minute las ich auch von, zum Teil auch von Journalisten, nicht nur von Fans, wo ich sage, gut, die genießen dann noch ein bisschen mehr Narrenfreiheit, las ich abschließende Beurteilungen dieses noch laufenden Halbfinals, inklusive Empfehlungen, wie man es hätte richtig machen müssen. Und ich muss sagen, ich finde das merkwürdig. Warum ist denn das so?
Ja, irgendwie scheinen sich ja alle diesem Trend anzuschließen, dass man möglichst schnell veröffentlichen muss, damit man noch der Erste ist, der dann diese Meinung vertritt. Und das machen ja Online-Medien sehr, sehr schnell. Man muss immer erstmal schon mal was veröffentlichen, damit man dann noch irgendwie bei irgendwelchen Google-Suchanfragen schnell dabei ist. Und das findet seinen Weg auch in die sozialen Netzwerke. Und ja, teilweise sogar, wie ich das gestern erlebt habe, an den Kneipentischen.
Das ist schon ein Phänomen. Ich meine, ich bin ja eigentlich Für-Meinung und ich finde auch, Journalismus sollte eine Haltung haben. Und ich versuche ja zum Beispiel auch im Rasenfunk immer mal wieder eine Haltung zu haben. Was mich so wahnsinnig stört, ist einfach dieses, und manchen unterstelle ich, dass sie es absichtlich machen, dass nicht mehr relativiert wird. Also dass gar nicht mehr gesagt wird. Das ist jetzt aber nur eine subjektive Einschätzung. Und es gibt noch Gegenthesen dazu, die auch vollkommen sauber durchargumentiert werden können. Es gibt halt kein richtig und kein falsch. Und natürlich darf jeder auch Kritik üben. Das ist vollkommen okay. Aber mir gefällt diese Absolutheit irgendwie nicht. Das steht auch vielen gar nicht so gut zu Gesicht. Weil es, mein Gott, wir reden hier über ein Fußballspiel. Was hätte es besser zeigen sollen als das 1 zu 0 jetzt im Halbfinale, um einen zu beweisen, da spielen Faktoren mit rein. Die kann kein Trainer der Welt vorhersehen, die kann man nicht trainieren. Es ist ein Fußballspiel, mein Gott. Das geht halt mal so und mal so aus. Und nicht immer gibt es dafür auch 100% schlüssige Begründungen, die einen richtig oder falsch zulassen.
Da hast du natürlich mit einem von einem Schiedsrichter-Podcast noch den Richtigen eingeladen. Das ist ja das, was wir seit der ersten Folge zu erleiden haben, dass die Leute immer unbedingt einen Richtig und einen Falsch haben wollen. Also gestern bei dem ersten Halbfinale, diese Szene, wo Ronaldo dann so eine Art Schwitzkasten genommen wird, und es schließt, dass es keinen Elfmeter gibt. Da schreibe ich dann irgendwie auf Twitter, kannst du geben oder kannst du einen Elfmeter geben? Und dann werde ich dafür sozusagen direkt angemacht, dass ich nicht schreibe, den muss man geben. Also das war dann schon wieder falsch. Also das ist halt immer so diese, wie du sagst, die Absolutheit in den Aussagen, ja, nervt, nervt.
Liegt das jetzt daran, dass ich vielleicht bei dieser EM so tief drin gesteckt war, wie noch selten in einem Turnier? Ich war schon immer sehr nerdig unterwegs, aber jetzt allein durch die Kurzpässe musste ich mich ja noch mehr damit beschäftigen. Oder hat das tatsächlich zugenommen? Denn mein Eindruck ist, dass es zugenommen hat.
Ja, immer schwierig zu sagen. Ich glaube, es hängt schon damit zusammen, dass man halt sehr viel da drin hängt. Ich glaube, wenn du jetzt einfach mal einen Tag Twitter ausmachen würdest zum Beispiel, dann wäre es wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr so schlimm. Aber es ist halt ein Verstärker. Gerade die sozialen Medien sind halt ein Verstärker von Meinungen. Der mit der klarsten Meinung ist ja dann auch der, der die meiste Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht. Und dadurch, das verstärkt dann auch wieder, dass Leute sich dazu gedrängt fühlen, möglichst schnell eine Meinung zu formulieren, damit sich viele dieser Meinung anschließen können.
Ja, ja, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, dass quasi die extremen, extreme Meinungen werden durch die Funktionsweise der sozialen Netzwerke unterstützt. Da hast du recht. Bestes Beispiel, wie kalkuliert die AfD kleine, virale Shitstorms auslösen kann. Nicht nur irgendwie, ja, Beatrice von Storch hat ja auch wieder so ein Tweet abgesetzt, wo ich stolz bin auf jeden, der das nicht retweetet und auch nicht screenshotet. Leute, jeder, der halbwegs eurer Meinung ist, der sagt auch, dass das vollkommen hirnverbrannt ist und die Frau total dumm ist. Und alle anderen, die eine andere Meinung haben, die werden euch sagen, du bist ein Gutmensch und so weiter. Die Diskussionen können wir uns sparen, lasst uns das ignorieren, wenn es irgendwie geht.
Ja, finde ich gut, dass man das auch mal in einem Fußball-Podcast einfach sagt. Es ist halt wirklich, es ist einfach das, was sie wollen. Und die Leute fallen jedes Mal wieder drauf rein, jeden Tag.
Und um jetzt quasi die Kurve zum Spiel zurückzubekommen. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ich meine, eigentlich, es gibt ja nichts Tolleres als über Fußball zu diskutieren. Ich meine, warum mache ich hier 200 Stunden Rasenfunk innerhalb von zwei Jahren? Ist ja klar. Und es ist ja auch vollkommen legitim, über Fußball zu diskutieren. Und vor allem ist das Tolle, du kommst nicht immer zu einem Ergebnis, sonst würde sich die Diskussion nämlich auch nicht lohnen. Denn sonst könnte ich das Ergebnis einer Diskussion nachlesen und dann wüsste ich, was ich zu glauben habe, nein, das sind Einschätzungsfragen. Aber was mir wirklich total fehlt, und das zieht sich jetzt auch ein bisschen durch die EM, ist dieses Zulassen von anderen Meinungen oder auch dieses Zurückstellen der eigenen Weisheit. Ich weiß nicht, das müssen jetzt die Hörer beurteilen. Vielleicht kommt das jetzt auch total heuchlerisch, weil ich mich vielleicht im Kurzpass ähnlich verhalte, aber ich versuche zumindest schon immer zu sagen, das ist jetzt meine Einschätzung, aber das ist nicht die einzige, die vielleicht richtig ist. Mein Gott, wer hat die Fußball-Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen, nicht mal mehr mit Scholl? Aber die Krauthöne verbreiten sie vielleicht auch nicht so schnell und wirksam.
Ich hab ja so eine Radio-Ausbildung gemacht und da gibt es immer auch Feedback-Regeln und bei Feedback ist es auch immer ganz wichtig, dass man immer sagt, das ist jetzt meine Meinung. Das ist jetzt nicht, du musst das so machen, sondern ich gebe dir den Hinweis, mach es doch mal so. Und diese Grauthöne sind natürlich auch durch die Begrenzzeit der Zeichen. Also du musst ja Meinung auch in möglichst kleinen Statements verpacken, damit es wahrgenommen wird. Da gehen die Grauthöne halt verloren. Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Deswegen ist Podcasten ja auch so schön, weil man da ja halt die Möglichkeit hat, da nochmal eine Meinung auszubreiten und dann in Gegenrede zu treten. Aber das ist halt auf vielen Ebenen nicht mehr so gewünscht. Du siehst das ja überall, dass viele Leute auch Probleme haben, längere Texte zu lesen oder sich mal die Zeit zu nehmen. Neulich gab es auch wieder diese Studie, dass viele Leute kommentieren, ohne überhaupt den Text gelesen zu haben.
Da hätte ich keine Studie für gebraucht. Ich habe als Box gearbeitet und die Community betreut. Das hätte ich dir sagen können.
Ja, aber Wissenschaft ist ja wichtig. Die müssen dann bestimmt. Das ist halt ein Trend, der sich so verfestigt. Viele Leute machen sich das, glaube ich, schon bewusst. Aber man hört halt oft eher die Lauten. Das ist immer so das Problem.
Ja, gut. Das war aber auch schon immer so, dass wird die Zeit einfach noch durch das Digitale noch verstärkt. Aber ich frage mich, da weiß ich jetzt auch gar nicht, was du noch so für eine Expertise mit in die Runde reinbringen kannst. Aber ist das denn in anderen Ländern auch so, dass gerade wenn es um den Fußball geht und gerade wenn es um die Nationalmannschaft geht, immer so schnell zu abschließenden Urteilen kommt? Also ich hatte den Eindruck, manche haben quasi auch nur darauf gewartet, mal wieder schreiben zu können, seht ihr, Joachim Löw hat es einfach nicht drauf. Und andere haben nur darauf gewartet, dass Leute so was schreiben, um schreiben zu können, was spinnst du, Halbfinale seit 2006 immer Minimum, wahnsinnig toller Trainer, er hat alles richtig gemacht. Was soll man bei den Ausfällen machen?
Ja, ich kann leider nicht so genau sagen, wie das in anderen Ländern ist, aber ich vermute, dass das überall ähnlich ist. Also gerade im Fußball, es ist ja halt auch alles irgendwie schon ausdiskutiert. Also welche Diskussion, die geführt wird, ist denn komplett neu?
Nicht mal die hier, klar.
Ja, es ist halt, man redet oft über dieselben Sachen, aber die Qualität der Diskussion, die lässt halt dann noch irgendwie nach.
Ja, und dann haben wir noch quasi das zweite Thema. Also das eine ist ja quasi das mit Argumenten über ein Spiel diskutieren. Und das zweite Thema ist, wenn sich die Enttäuschung in Aggression bahnen bricht. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht körperliche Aggression, sondern verbale Aggression. Also was heißt dieselben Leute? Wenn ich Zeit hätte, würde ich dazu mal eine Studie machen, wie viele Leute, die Chezouis Paris geschrieben haben am 13. November, jetzt in ihren Tweets das Wort Froschfresser verwendet haben nach dem Spiel. Und das hast du ja am deutlichsten am Schiedsrichter gemerkt. Wo dann auf einmal klar ist, na der musste ja einen Elfmeter gegen uns pfeifen, denn der ist ja Italiener. Der kann ja gar nicht anders, Klaas.
Ich finde es ganz witzig, wird ja so gesagt, Italien ist rausgeflogen, jetzt ist der Rizzoli so sauer, dass er die Deutschen verpfeift. Man kann das ja auch andersrum sehen. Man kann einfach sagen, der Rizzoli ist total glücklich, dass Italien raus ist, weil so konnte er noch ein Halbfinale leiten. Der wäre ja sonst nach Hause gefahren, wenn Italien weitergekommen wäre. Es ist genauso unsinnig, das Argument, aber man kann es ja auch mal anführen. Wir hatten ja diese Diskussion bei Collinas Erben in der letzten Saison auch, warum zum Beispiel Felix Brüch keine Spiele von Bayern München leiten darf, weil er ja irgendwie in München wohnt. Da haben wir schon gesagt, eigentlich ist das gar nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Weil Felix Brüch wird nicht auf den Platz gehen und nur für Bayern pfeifen. Das wird er einfach nicht machen. Und da unterhalte ich mit Bundesliga-Schiedsrichtern, die sagen, wenn ich auf dem Platz stehe, dann sehe ich nicht mehr den Verein oder irgendwelche Vorgeschichten, dann leite ich dieses eine Spiel. Und ich weiß, wenn ich hier Fehler mache, dann wird mir das überall vorgehalten. Deswegen werde ich mich bemühen, keine zu tun. Und der Rizzoli, ich meine, man muss ja auch einfach mal sagen, diese Entscheidung, diesen Elfenmeter zu pfeifen, wer hätte denn das gesehen? Der Strafraumrichter hat es scheinbar gesehen, hat es dem Rizzoli gesagt, also perfekte Teamarbeit, und da muss man einfach nur sagen, Hut ab, Chapeau, alles richtig gesehen. Und dann wird trotzdem noch so getan, als hätte er Deutschland verpfiffen. Also irgendwie ist das doch, es ist ja auch absurd.
Gut, ich meine, auch das war natürlich eine grau Entscheidung. Ich finde, ich kann auch schon diejenigen verstehen, die sagen, er wurde angeköpft und kann den Arm dann logischerweise nicht wegziehen. Und irgendwie brauchst du die Arme auch in Balance zu halten. Also ich finde auch, es ist kein Muss-Elfmeter.
Ja, aber du hast halt die Regel, wenn du die Hände überm Kopf hast, dann wird, also dieses Handspiel ist ja so eine ganz komische Regelauslegung mittlerweile geworden. Hier mit vergrößerter Körperfläche und so weiter. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen abstrus teilweise. Aber es gibt halt diesen Punkt, wenn die Hände überm Kopf sind, dann ist es halt Absicht. Das hast du bei Boateng gesehen. Der wollte ja auch nicht absichtlich den Ball mit der Hand spielen, aber er hat den halt da abgekriegt. Und so war es bei Schweinsteiger auch. Und von daher würde ich halt eher sagen, das ist zu 90 Prozent ein Ja-Elfmeter. Und natürlich gibt es die 10 Prozent, wo man sagen kann, okay, ist aus der Bewegung und so. Aber die Regelauslegung ist korrekt.
Okay, stimmt. Das hätte ich eigentlich wissen müssen, weil ich ja euch höre. Und jetzt, als du es gesagt hast, mit dem Handy über den Kopf, dachte ich mir, ach ja, stimmt, da war ja was so was Dobes. Ich finde ja, dass dieser Frust, der sich dann entleert, also im Stadion Brötmanns, vorm Fernseher Brötmanns, auf der Fernmalle Brötmanns, im Internet schreibt man es, das kann ich irgendwie, ich kann den Mechanismus dahinter verstehen. Du bist frustriert, dass Deutschland 0 zu 1 hinten liegt. Der Schiedsrichter ist ein Italiener. Du siehst den Elfmeter aus deiner Sicht heraus als ungerechtfertigt. Okay, ich verstehe dann nicht so ganz, wo dann der Transfer herkommt, dann immer gleich so zu schimpfen. Und ich verstehe jetzt auch nicht, warum man außerhalb von den Simpsons wirklich noch Froschwitze über Frankreich machen muss. Aber okay, ich verstehe den Mechanismus dahinter. Aber was ich wirklich langsam, ja, also was ich irgendwie nicht mal so wirklich nachvollziehen kann, ist dieses Nicht-mehr-akzeptieren von Zufällen. Das war doch schon immer so, dass der Zufall eine Rolle gespielt hat im Fußball. Und Glück und Pech. Und schau dir an, wie wir ins Finale gekommen sind, 2002. Und schau dir an, wie wir zum Teil ausgeschieden sind, 2010. Standard-Situation, Puyol und Müller ist gelb gesperrt. Ja, das sind halt zwei Faktoren. Und woher kommt denn, dass man das heutzutage immer alles gleich erklären möchte? Ich habe ganz wenige Leute, die gesagt haben, ja ist halt leider manchmal so, manchmal reicht es halt einfach nicht. Aber für mich fühlt sich dieses Spiel genau danach an, ja manchmal reicht es halt einfach nicht. Das ist halt so im Fußball.
Im Prinzip ist der beste Beweis dafür, wie wichtig der Zufall im Fußball ist, gibt es da nicht, aber es gab doch hier in einer Sportgeschule, haben sie so ein neues Messverfahren jetzt auch wieder entwickelt und die sagen halt auch, es ist immer noch so, egal wie viel System du bei den Spielern irgendwie implementierst, 50 Prozent der Tore minimum fallen immer noch durch Zufall, also durch abgefälschte Bälle oder auch mit dem Pfosten oder was weiß ich. Also es gibt einfach, klar du kannst immer versuchen bestimmte Systeme zu spielen, aber die meisten oder die Hälfte der Tore fallen halt immer noch durch Zufälle. Und das Spiel gestern hat halt gezeigt, die Franzosen waren halt das glücklichere Team irgendwie. Also die Deutschen haben es ja nicht schlecht gemacht. Also gerade in der ersten Halbzeit fand ich zwar, war starker Fußball und das mit einer Truppe, die ja nun auch sehr ersatzgeschwächt war, haben trotzdem ein sehr gutes Spiel abgeliefert. Ich hatte irgendwie so das Gefühl, Deutschland hat eine, alle, also alle Spieler auf dem Platz haben eine gewisse Klasse, kommt man auch nicht immer bei die deutsche Mannschaft sagen, in den letzten Jahrzehnten, aber alle Spieler hatten eine bestimmte Klasse, aber es haben halt viele nicht auf ihrer bevorzugten Position spielen können. Und das hat halt dann irgendwie auch dazu geführt, dass man sich nicht die ganz klaren Torchance noch ausgespielt hat. Und die Franzosen hatten jetzt auch nicht die überragenden Tormöglichkeiten. Guck dir beide Tore an, das war jetzt auch nicht wunderbar ausgespielt, aber die klaren Torchancen hatten sie dennoch. Also die Höhe des Gretche zum Beispiel, wenn Giro sich da ein bisschen cleverer anstellt, dann ist das ja eine Riesen-Torchance. Und da muss man das auch einfach akzeptieren, dass die Franzosen da, es muss ja auch nicht immer alles hundertprozentig verdient sein. Also muss ja nicht mal sagen, es hat die bessere Mannschaft gewonnen, aber die Franzosen haben zumindest nicht unverdient gewonnen.
Und dann kommt man halt schon schnell auch zum Faktor Form. Also einige Spieler haben auch einfach nicht ihre Bestform erreicht, Minimum in diesem Spiel. Und bei einigen Spieler vor allem Thomas Müller im gesamten Turnier. Und Form kannst du aber auch Spielern schwer vorwerfen, denn auch das gehört zum Sport dazu. Ich finde halt, das, wo man dann tatsächlich anfangen kann zu diskutieren, ist eben, okay, wenn man jetzt quasi attestiert, Thomas Müller ist nicht in seiner Form, hätte da nicht vielleicht eine Konsequenz sein können, entweder ihn ersetzen oder ihn in andere Situationen zu bringen, wo es leichter für ihn ist. Vielleicht war der Kader nicht auf den Fall hin ausgerichtet, dass das Gommis ausfällt. Ich finde, das sind Diskussionen, die kannst du führen, weil das ist quasi auf einer... Es geht zwar aus von einem weichen Faktor, von dem Faktor Form, der schwierig ist zu beeinflussen, aber es geht quasi nicht damit weiter, dass man sagt, der Löw hat es nicht geschafft, den zu motivieren, oder er hätte ihn irgendwie auf die Bank setzen sollen, so wie es mit Griezmann gemacht wurde bei Frankreich, der danach viel deutlicher zurückkam.
Aber die Debatte zum Beispiel bei Gommis ist dann ja auch wieder, wen hätte er denn noch mitnehmen sollen? Aber wäre das dann ja der große Golgetter gewesen, und klar kann man auch sagen, er hätte vielleicht in der Vorrunde mal einen, zwei Spieler schonen sollen, aber das sind ja auch irgendwie Scheindebatten. Also wenn man halt auch sieht, guck mal die WM 2014, da wird ja jetzt so getan, als ob man da alles perfekt gespielt hätte, guckt man sich das Spiel gegen Algerien an zum Beispiel, da war das halt auch alles auf Messerschneide. Wenn man da irgendwie rausgeflogen, dann hätte man auch alles in Grund und Boden geredet und Joachim Löw wäre jetzt nicht mehr Bundestrainer. Man hatte halt das nötige Glück und man war auch eine tolle Mannschaft, hat da super gespielt, aber man muss halt so ein bisschen die Anerkennung auch gegenüber den anderen Mannschaften davon halt nicht fallen lassen, aus meiner Sicht. Also man darf nicht immer so tun, wir haben jetzt hier die super goldene Generation und der Schweinsteiger, der hat sich immer so reingekämpft und hat so gegen seinen Körper jetzt trotzdem nochmal da irgendwie alles gegeben, deutsche Tugenden und so. Ist ja alles richtig, aber auch einfach zu sagen, in einem Halbfinale kann man halt auch durch zwei blöde Fehler einfach mal verlieren.
Genau, das berühmte Niveau. Vielleicht ist das vielleicht die eine inhaltliche Debatte, die man jetzt auch mit ein paar Tagen Abstand mitnehmen kann, ob sich eventuell der Fußball dahin entwickelt hat, dass du wieder klassischere Mittelstürmer bräuchtest oder es zumindest dir gut zu Gesicht steht. Also sprich, wir hatten jetzt mit Mario Gomez jemanden dabei, der sehr groß ist und der gewisse Qualitäten hat in der Luft, am Boden, aber eben nicht der kleine Wusler ist. Auf der Gegenseite hattest du mit Chris Mann aber auch den Beweis, es geht auch mit dem kleinen Wusler, der am Ball alles kann. Allerdings braucht der auch ein bisschen Anlauf, also sprich, den musst du anders irgendwie ins Spiel bringen. Ist das vielleicht so eine inhaltliche Debatte, die man jetzt nach dem Turnier weiternehmen kann? Denn tatsächlich drängen sich nicht so viele deutsche Stürmer, die so etwas können, auf. Wenn du mal Stefan Kießling aus dem Vorlässt, aus gewissen Gründen ist er irgendwie für die Nationalmannschaft nicht relevant. Ist das vielleicht so was? Ja, ernsthaft, an den habe ich tatsächlich gestern auch gedacht. Man mag von ihm halten, was man will. Ich glaube, er hätte eine Haltung mitgebracht, die die Deutschen in diesem Spiel Minimum nicht hatten.
Na ja, es hat halt ein Abnehmer für die Flanken dann auch irgendwo gefehlt. Das war halt schon ein Problem. Ich glaube, es ist halt immer das Problem, dass du dann auch auf eine gewisse Art irgendwann ein bisschen ausrechenbar wirst. Also die haben sich halt auch die ganzen deutschen Spiele angeguckt und wussten, wie die agieren, ohne Stürmer vielleicht, und haben ihre Gegenmittel und da muss man halt wieder was Neues erfinden. Deswegen war ja die Idee, Gommis überhaupt mitzunehmen. Die war ja schon mal gut. Das muss man ja einfach auch mal attestieren. Hat ja auch nicht jeder gesagt, wow, das ist super, dass er den Gommis mitnimmt. Er hat es ja gemacht. Er hat ihn mitgenommen, obwohl er ja quasi raus war über zwei Jahre irgendwie. Und dann kann man natürlich jetzt die Debatte anfangen, brauchen wir jetzt mehr wieder diesen neuen, diesen alten Stürmer-Typ. Ich glaube, die Stürmer, die da vorne drin sind und die dann groß sind, die müssen halt mittlerweile mehr können. Also ich vergleiche das so ein bisschen mit den Torhütern vielleicht auch. Die mussten ja auch irgendwann lernen, Fußball zu spielen. Und ein Mittelstürmer, da reicht es halt auch nicht, wenn du immer nur vorne drin stehst und auf die Flanken wartest, sondern du hast halt andere Aufgaben. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass ich da in den nächsten Jahren einfach auch was tun wird. Also dass man auf der Position, die wichtigste Position ist ja nun mal die desjenigen, der die Tore vorbereitet oder schießt, dass man da halt auch das größte Potenzial wahrscheinlich jetzt entdeckt. Auf den Außenbahnen schätze ich, wird sich einiges tun und im Sturmzentrum. Ich glaube, das sind so die entscheidenden Positionen, wo wir in den nächsten Jahren neue Ideen sehen werden.
Da haben jetzt, glaube ich, einige Sechser und Torhüter aufgehaut, als du gesagt hast, der Stürmer ist die wichtigste Position.
Nein, aber ich meine wirklich ganz platt, wenn man wirklich mal von dem ausgeht, wer schießt denn die Tore, dann sind es meistens nicht die Sechser und nicht die Torhüter.
Das stimmt. Das war übrigens auch noch ein Gedanke, den ich gestern während des Spiels schon hatte, weil du angesprochen hast, ihnen haben die Lösungen gefehlt und sie waren ausrechenbar. Ein bisschen hat mich tatsächlich Deutschland jetzt im Spiel gegen Frankreich und auch im Spiel gegen Italien, aber da noch nicht ganz so frappant, an die erste Saison Bayern unter Pep Guardiola erinnert, wo sie auch schon ein sehr, sehr gefälliges Spiel aufgezogen haben, sind ja auch dominant Meister geworden. Allerdings hast du gerade in den internationalen Spielen und gerade in den Champions League-Halbfinalspielen dann gesehen, der Gegner stellt sich auf das ein, was die Bayern gespielt haben zu dieser Zeit. Und da sind die quasi nur über zwei Wege in den Strafraum gekommen. Und einer davon war, wir kommen über Schnittstellenpässe an die Grundlinie und passen dann in den Rückraum oder kurz an den Fünfer. Meistens übrigens in den Rückraum, das mag der Pep irgendwie lieber. Und die zweite Variante war der absolute Plan B, wir schlagen eine Flanke rein. Das war das, was Guardiola zugelassen hat bei den Bayern, was er bei Barca nicht zugelassen hat. Und im dritten Jahr unter Guardiola, gegen Atletico dann, sind die Bayern auf so viele verschiedene Arten und Weise in den Strafraum gekommen. Das war ein Prachtspiel. Auch da hing es viel am Faktor Zufall, Glück, Pech, dass es nicht geklappt hat mit der Finalteilnahme der Bayern. Und vielleicht ist das auch so eine Sache, die man mitnehmen kann aus diesem Ausscheiden. Und ich finde auch so ein bisschen aus dem Turnier, dass Deutschland etwas eindimensional gespielt hat in dem, was man nach vornehin angeboten hat.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob man wirklich so eindimensional war. Also gerade wenn man die erste Halbzeit guckt, haben die Offensivleute viel angeboten. Also haben auch viele Laufwege gemacht. Aber es war halt auch sehr, sehr eng. Die Franzosen haben sich halt auch sehr, sehr tief positioniert mit der kompletten Mannschaft.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber zum Beispiel jetzt mal so vertikal gespielte Pässe in den 16er, da kann ich mich nur an einen Doppelpass mit groß erinnern, wo er dann so ganz leicht gefault wird. Also nie im Leben ein Straffstoß. Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, viel über die Außen, das ist ja auch vollkommen okay. Gerade die Spieleröffnung Boateng auf Hektor oder Kimmich hat geklappt, aber dann tatsächlich auch selten bis an die Grundlinie gekommen. Er den Weg nach innen gegangen in dem Bereich, der eh schon dicht war. Also ich fand schon, dass es da Muster gab im deutschen Spiel, die sich über 90 Minuten immer wieder wiederholt haben.
Ja, und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass man schon bewusst auch versucht hat oder nicht oft versucht hat, das durch die Mitte zu machen, weil man Sorge hatte, sich blöde Konter zu füllen. Wenn du da den Ball verlierst und Pokba, Grießmann und Co. abgehen, dann hast du halt ein richtiges Problem. Das waren ja dann auch die großen Chancen der Franzosen. Also ich denke mal, dass das auch so ein bisschen der Plan war, dass man halt da nicht die Bälle verliert. Das kann man jetzt im Nachhinein natürlich sagen. Man muss da ein bisschen mehr versuchen, ein bisschen riskanter spielen, lässt sich hinterher leicht sagen. Aber ich kann den Plan dann halt auch irgendwie verstehen, dass man da diese Stärke den Franzosen halt nehmen will, indem man den Ball da gar nicht verliert.
Ach ja, das ist ein sehr, sehr guter Punkt. Da hast du schon recht, Klaas. Das muss man auch mit in die Argumentation mit einbeziehen. Es wäre so viel einfacher, wenn man einfach nach dem Spiel, sowie das FBI irgendwann seine confidential eingestuften Unterlagen öffnet und man was über die Area 51 in den 50ern erfährt, dass man nach dem Spiel einfach den Matchland vorgelegt bekommt. Beide Trainer sagen, also so wollte ich spielen, jetzt mal ohne Geflunker, ganz ehrlich, das war mein Plan. Und dann kann man das abgleichen und dann würde man vielleicht auch manchen Spieler fairer bewerten, weil man auch, also Klassiker, man wirft dem Außenverteidiger vor, er hat offensiv zu wenig gemacht, vielleicht war aber halt sein Arbeitsauftrag, du gehst nicht arg weit über die Mittellinie, weil dein Gegenspieler ist wahnsinnig gefährlich und die spielen asymmetrischen Aufbau über deine Seite.
Man denkt ja immer, da kommen wir wieder so ein bisschen an den Anfang dieser Folge zurück, man denkt ja von außen immer, dass man genau weiß, welcher Plan da verfolgt wird. Das ist ja schon die Grundannahme. Genau und das ist halt schon immer, man wirft den Leuten Sachen vor, ohne dass man vielleicht weiß, wie es wirklich geplant war. Das ist halt schon immer das Schwierige. Und da kann man sich halt glaube ich wirklich teilweise so ein bisschen mehr Zurückhaltung auch wünschen, auch in bestimmten Texten und Tweets und Facebook-Mitteilungen und so. Fände ich schon ganz gut, wenn man da so ein bisschen zurückhaltender würde.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen, das hört sich zwar immer nach fieser Moralkeule an, aber ich finde tatsächlich, es sollte so ein Demutembargo geben, bis vier Stunden nach Spielende nur nur demütig sein und erst mal die Füße stillhalten und dann kann man ja auch gerne die Analyse gehen. Ich denke jetzt auch anders über das Spiel als gestern. Das wird man auch hören, wenn man die Schlusskonferenz jetzt mit dem Vergleich, was wir hier besprochen haben. Das ist einfach ein Prozess und es gibt schon die Leute, die das gleich können. Und das sind halt dann auch wirklich gute Journalisten. Und da lese ich mir dann auch sehr, sehr gerne die Analysen durch, die helfen mir dann auch selber noch mal meine Meinung zum Spiel zu hinterfragen. Aber diese Gabel, ein Spiel so zu analysieren, dass man quasi aus so einer Position raus darüber schreiben kann, als würde man sich es quasi noch mal in der Wiederholung angucken. Eine Woche nachdem es passiert ist, das haben halt nicht viele. Ja, und vielleicht schließt sich da tatsächlich der Kreis. Und früher hast du das halt einfach über Zeitung, hast du am nächsten Tag, du hast halt deinen Agenturbericht bekommen, der halt meistens deskriptiv ist und in den guten Zeitungen hast du halt dann wirklich sehr, sehr gute Einordnungen von Journalisten bekommen, die nichts anderes seit Jahren machen und die auch ein bisschen eher dazu fähig sind, diese Aufgeregtheit des Spiels zu abstrahieren und aus ihren Texten rauszuhalten, wenn es den Texten gut tut. Und jetzt durch die digitalen Medien kann sich aber jeder äußern und nicht nur solche Journalisten.
Das fehlt dann teilweise tatsächlich so dieses Journalist geht noch mal in die Mix-Zonen oder auf eine Pressekonferenz und stellt eine Frage an den Spieler oder an den Trainer und bekommt vielleicht sogar noch eine Antwort und kann daraus dann auch wieder was ableiten. Deswegen ist es ja so schön zum Beispiel den Sportteil in der Süddeutschen am Montag noch mal zu lesen, weil man da dann noch mal eine andere Reflektion drin hat. Das fehlt manchmal, aber wie gesagt, wie du es auch gesagt hast, ich bewundere das bei einigen Leuten, die das wirklich sehr schnell können, die sehr schnell ihre Analysen da fertig schreiben. Die haben ja oft auch dann viel mehr Fußball geguckt. Als ich das getan habe, kennen sich mit den einzelnen Leuten viel mehr aus. Das ist dann immer ein ganz guter Anhaltspunkt, aber ja, ein bisschen weniger schwarz-weiß manchmal tut der Sache dann auch gut.
Ein Plädoyer für Krauthöne, ja, tatsächlich. Und meine Beobachtung ist ja tatsächlich, am ehesten kommen diese klugen Gedanken und Analysen von Menschen, die das sehr, sehr gut können, tatsächlich auch tatsächlich in akustischer Version rüber. Also damit mache ich nicht nur Werbung für Podcasts, also ich finde, das mag man auch bei Euro Daily, dem Format vom Guardian, da habe ich jetzt jede Folge WM gehört und die holen sich ja die Journalisten zum Teil noch, während die auf den Trainer auf der Pressekonferenz warten, holen die sich den schon ins Gespräch und die können das eben. Und da kommt aber halt dann noch der Vorteil dazu, wir beide diskutieren jetzt auch über das Spiel oder beziehungsweise über das, was danach passiert ist und dadurch hat sich meine Meinung auch schon wieder leicht ausdifferenziert, weil ich von dir Argumente mit rein nehme in meine Überlegungen und so ist das halt bei diesen Journalisten auch. Das heißt, das akustische Format ist auch echt nochmal, das hilft. Also wenn du mit jemandem, der so was gut kann, direkt nach Abfiff redest, unheimlich Erkenntnis bringt. Das mochte ich auch immer ehrlich gesagt vor Ort in den Stadien am liebsten. Also ich bin da nicht in den Journalistenrunden gestanden, es gibt auch welche, da wird viel geblökt und viel, naja klar, da kann halt nichts und der groß muss weg und bla. Aber es gibt ja auch die Journalisten, die jetzt dem Mindset von uns beiden näher sind und sich mit denen dann übers Spiel zu unterhalten, direkt danach, dass es unheimlich gewinnbringt. So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie diese Folge ankommt. Ich hoffe, wir haben uns nicht auf einen zu hohen Thron gesetzt irgendwie.
Wir haben ja beide zugegeben, dass wir nichts wissen.
Ja, und gleichzeitig haben wir aber schon auch geurteilt.
Ich glaube, wer das jetzt hört, man kann ja dieses Gespräch verfolgen und daraus hören, dass es halt kein richtig und kein falsch jetzt gibt. Und ich glaube, man muss auch jedem zugestehen, dass er mal einen blöden Tweet raushaut oder mal eine falsche Meinung vertritt. Aber die Erkenntnis, gerade jetzt auch nach so einem Turnier, ist ja dann irgendwie auch wieder, wenn man jetzt sich so Sachen aus der Vorrunde anguckt oder wenn wir auch im Podcast über irgendwelche Schiedsrichter-Szenen von vor drei Monaten reden, es ist teilweise die Aufregung halt nicht wert. Und manchmal ist die Aufregung halt einfach auch nur gepusht, um überhaupt irgendwas verkaufen zu können. Und da muss man halt auch ein bisschen differenzieren und muss sich nicht an allem beteiligen.
Da hast du recht und ich hätte nie gesagt, dass ich diesen Satz on air mal sage, aber es ist halt doch nur Fußball. Und ohne Niederlagen, die man hin und wieder einstecken würde, würde man sich tatsächlich über die Siege, die dann auch irgendwann kommen in der Zukunft, mein Gott, wir haben doch noch alles so viel vor uns, auch gar nicht so sehr freuen. Das ist vice versa, erlebe ich das ja gerade bei ganz vielen Bayern-Fans, die sich über Siege nicht mehr so richtig freuen können. Und bei Niederlagen dann ganz schmerzerfüllt aufheulen, weil das kann ja gar nicht sein, dass man gegen Gladbach verliert. Es gehört halt beides dazu zum Fußball. Es gibt auch keine Pizza ohne Rand, ist halt so. Und wenn es den Rand aber nicht gäbe, dann könnte man den Mittelteil halt auch nicht würdigen. Und ich möchte jetzt bitte keine Rand-Rands von irgendwelchen Leuten, die auf den Rand stehen, bekommen. Ihr habt es alle nicht verstanden. Den Rand braucht niemand. Okay, aber mit Käse wird eh alles besser. Mit Käse wäre sogar das Ausscheiden noch besser geworden. Hätte man mir direkt nach dem Spiel irgendwas mit Käse über Backnis hingestellt, hätte ich da auch eine ganz andere Schlusskonferenz hingelegt. Tiefenentspannt. Ach Käse. Und damit sind wir den Veganern auf die Füße getreten. Ach, es ist einfach schwierig. Wollen wir das Ding hier mal zumachen, Klaas?
Ich denke auch.
Ich würde auch.
Hat trotzdem Spaß gemacht.
Mir auch, vielen Dank. Klaas Reese, meine Damen und Herren, Edsportkultur bei Twitter. Wann hören wir die nächste Collinas-Erben-Folge?
Wenn Alex aus dem Urlaub zurück ist, der weilt gerade in Kroatien und wenn er dann wieder da ist, dann quatschen wir mal in aller Ruhe über die Schiedsrichterentscheidung.
Cool, darauf freuen wir uns. Hört da rein, Collinas-Erben. Und wir, liebe Hörer, hören uns morgen. Ui, dann gibt es eine kleine Ankündigung im Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, macht's gut.